So overnight.
We're tracking breaking news
out of Washington
after Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell has been hospitalized
after he tripped
and fell at a hotel in Washington.
I want to bring in our CNN
congressional correspondent, Lauren Fox.
Lauren, what do we know?
What do we not know from McConnell's team
so far about what happened?
Yeah, what
we know at this moment,
Caitlin, is that
he did
suffer a fall
at the Waldorf Astoria Hotel
following a private dinner.
I want to read
this statement from his office
saying this evening, Leader
McConnell tripped at a local hotel
during a private dinner.
He has been admitted to the hospital
where he is receiving treatment.
Now, McConnell is 81 years old.
He's the top Republican in the U.S.
Senate and the longest
serving Republican leader in that body.
But there's just a lot
we don't know right now
about his condition,
about how long
he'll have to be at the hospital.
It also comes at a time, Caitlin,
when the Senate is narrowly
divided right now
and there are two Democratic senators
who are also out for health reasons.
You have Senator Dianne Feinstein,
who is dealing with shingles.
You also have Senator John Fetterman,
the Pennsylvania Democrat
who is receiving treatment
for clinical depression
at Walter Reed right now.
So, you know,
there's just a lot of questions.
I will keep you updated
as we get more information this morning.
But right now,
what we know
is that McConnell suffered a fall
last night
and was hospitalized
after that fell silent.
He's obviously in our thoughts.
We're hoping for a quick recovery
for him.
But, Lauren, in the broader
impact of what this means is
we've had these conversations
when Senator Fetterman was hospitalized.
Senator Feinstein,
what does it mean for Senate
leadership, given
if he does
need quite some time to recover
Well, I think there's just a lot
we don't know right now.
But obviously, it's a narrowly
divided body.
It is a body
in which
McConnell has a lot of jurisdiction
over his conference.
He is somebody
who is revered
within his conference, trusted
someone that lawmakers
go to for advice,
someone who decides
the Republican strategy in the U.S.
Senate.
So obviously, his absence
for any period of time
will have an impact
on the Republican conference.
Of course, you also have Senator
John Thune, who is the next in line.
He is the Republican whip who,
you know,
would be expected to fill that vacuum.
But we just don't know right now
how long McConnell
would be hospitalized for
and how serious of a fall this was.
Caitlin.
All right. Lauren Fox, keep us updated.
Thank you so much.
I want to bring in CNN's
political commentator Errol Louis
for more on this Errol, obviously, we are
we don't know a lot.
We're hoping to learn more
and we're wishing for the best
for Senator McConnell.
But this does have a significant impact
potentially on how things work
in Washington
for any senator,
but especially one is powerful
in his caucus as Mitch McConnell.
Oh, for sure.
We should keep in mind
that it is still a closely
divided Senate.
We had the vice president
come in
and break some ties
on judicial nominations
of no particular moment.
That's how closely
we still have to keep in mind.
51 49 is nothing to sneeze at.
And all it takes
is one or two to be incapacitated
or not in the chamber.
And all of a sudden,
a lot of things can change.
But I think your larger point, though,
the the interesting thing about McConnell
is that
we don't know where the Senate would go
without him.
He's you know, he's
the longest
serving Republican leader in history.
And where they might go,
you look at somebody
like Senator Rick Scott,
who made an abortive challenge to
maybe take the leadership away.
And he put forward some policies
that were dramatically unpopular
and was sort of shunted aside
and so forth.
But we don't know where that conference
would go
without the leadership of Mitch
McConnell.
We may find out.
Find out in the next few weeks.
Oh, sorry.
Is there anything that they're working on
now that would be in jeopardy
because of a Mitch McConnell absence
that is of critical importance
at this moment?
I think
I think, you know, broadly
speaking, trying
to figure out
what the strategy is going to be.
I mean, you know, Senator Biden
I mean, I should say President Biden is
is is putting together
and getting ready to announce
he's making a speech today
that is going to really,
I think, sort of lay the groundwork,
set the table
for an announcement for president.
Where are the Republicans going to go?
What's their answer going to be?
There's a relative amount of chaos
over on the House side.
And so you would
try and look to the Senate.
What are the policies
that we're going to pick on again?
You know,
Senator Scott talks about,
you know, budget
deficit reduction and it's strayed into
maybe we need to cut Medicare,
maybe we need to cut Social Security.
Third, rail in politics, a disaster
sort of swept aside.
Where do they go now? We don't know.
I just was going to say,
I mean, obviously,
we know the longest serving, you know,
Senate Republican leader in history,
but also an important voice this week
following that Fox News
report, trying to whitewash January six
when he came out.
What he said,
just, you know,
thinking about that in the context of.
Sure.
I mean, this is now
this is what the Senate is
and this is what the Senate
is supposed to be.
You know,
the median age in the US
Senate is close to 65.
There are a lot of older members there,
but they represent and,
you know,
whatever their politics
they represent
sort of institutional continuity,
a sort of way of cooling off
some of the passions that are dividing
the nation and so forth.
And we already saw
just a little bit of that.
You know,
the whole question
of trying to relitigate January 6th
and this attack,
you know,
you're relying on elders
like Mitch McConnell to say, again,
even if you don't like his politics
and stand up and say,
no, that was a disaster.
That was something where
we're going to stick to the facts.
We're not going to see a repeat of this.
We have to safeguard
the institutions of the country.
Yeah, and you're right.
He's saying that
what it was
it was critical
what he
what Mitch McConnell said, that
he's standing by police
and the police assessment
and rather than the Fox News
assessment front of the cameras.